this is what many in lampedusa want that
Island to be famous for its jaggedly
beautiful landscape its sparkling coves
it's Seafood its Traditions januca
Cucina despairs that it's known instead
for its repeated migration emergencies
causing uncertainty for would-be
tourists and the families like his who
rely on them
they always ask what's the latest with
migrants and we're exhausted we can't
work in peace and promote our beautiful
Island
this isn't the first time that Italy has
seen this kind of level of seaborne
arrivals but the difference is the
proportion back in 2015 2016 that number
was about eight percent this year the
proportion of arrivals arriving into
lampedusa is 70 percent
last week's sudden surgeon numbers
brought demands from prime minister
Georgia Maloney for an EU Naval mission
is Seeking a yet broader International
response at the U.N general assembly in
New York
German
day
lucrative than the trafficking of
migrants when it is the U.N reports
themselves that have shown how this
business has reached by volume of money
the same level of drug trafficking
back on lampedusa John Luca's mother is
cooking in the family restaurant he and
his father run boat trips he says Milani
is failing like her predecessors to
address their concerns
they need to tell us the truth Meloni
fooled us with the talk of a never
blockade which never went anywhere that
exploited lampedusa even more in 24
hours more than 8 000 people arrived
the situation is now far less acute but
still hundreds of migrants arrive daily
the Reception Center still well over
capacity
the Island's priest says its people will
continue to do what they can to treat
them with
dignity's people are not tired of
migrants in fact we've seen more cases
of emergency and the welcome has
remained the same the people are tired
of political power that doesn't take
note of the real emergency guaranteeing
dignity to everyone
but others here talk of a general shift
towards a harder line at a public
meeting on Wednesday persistent rumors
resurfaced that the government wants to
build a repatriation center here housing
people who don't qualify for Asylum for
up to 18 months
John Luca says that would destroy the
island that he would use any means to
fight it Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera
lampedusa foreign
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera